in the iconic bridge fight from
spider-man no way home dr octopus's
tentacles were the work of the visual
effects team but on set the car and
these exploding water barrels were very
real
even if we're gonna replace all that and
have digital versions of things if you
can shoot something it's always better
that's visual effects supervisor scott
edelstein his team collaborated with
special effects supervisor dan suddick
to find the right mix of practical and
digital to create no way home's
action-packed bridge fight like when doc
octopus first emerges with his
mechanical arms
to really sell the strength of these cgi
arms dan devised a way to crush the cars
practically into what the crew called
taco cars i saw the previous i thought
wow wouldn't it be great if we could
just pull down the center of the car
very hard and just let the car fold up
by itself first dan built a steel
platform with a hole in the middle then
he placed the car on top of it and
attached two cables to the bottom center
of the car pulling it through while it's
split in half
shots like this one hello peter where
doc och was simply suspended in the air
or equally challenging
unlike in 2004 spider-man 2 alfred
molina did not wear a pair of
puppeteered claws on set while the actor
now had more flexibility to move around
digital domain would have to know how to
place his arms in the shot especially
when they held him up like this
the best visual effects references
depended on how high his body was above
the ground which varied throughout
sometimes the crew could use tables to
lift him up letting him move his real
legs around more freely but it wasn't
very comfortable
other times he was strapped to a tuning
fork where crew members could steer and
turn him from behind as seen here when
he pulled himself up from under the
bridge when the arms brought him down to
the ground they used a moving platform
that could be lowered and operated like
a technocrane
this got even trickier for the vfx team
as the sequence progressed and the
character interacted more and more with
his surroundings john watts the director
really wants to have his movements make
sense and to have weight so you don't
want him to feel light or any of the
things that he's interacting with to
feel like this meant establishing clear
physics about what he could and couldn't
do for example he always had at least
two hands on the ground supporting him
for balance even as he lifted two cars
at once
the way he handled objects also needed
careful consideration he steps forward
and throws a car gets to transfer that
weight and like another arm has to go
land on the ground to hold him up as
he's throwing the car forward the
practical team also applied these rules
to props used in the fight like here
when doc ock throws a gigantic pipe at
spider-man and instead crushes a car
dan and lead visual effects supervisor
kelly port wanted the pipe to fall like
a baseball bat so it had to practically
collapse at an angle rather than flat it
basically is faster at the tip and
slower at the handle to achieve this
unique effect dan used two cables to
hold the concrete and steel pipe
straight each cable was attached to a
pneumatic cylinder which released air
pressure at different speeds we could
force the tip of the pipe down into the
car faster than the front of the pipe
would fall and then we'd pull the front
of the pipe at a certain speed but that
only took them so far during an initial
test the pipe crushed the top of the car
but not its size so the sides were
actually weakened beforehand by cutting
out the door frames then the crew hid
cables inside the car so when the pipe
collapsed the cables brought the sides
of the car down with it
now it would have been too dangerous for
tom holland and his devils to actually
dodge that pipe so for this shot the
action elements in the frame were shot
separately and combined in
post-production
in one take tom rolled over the hood of
a car to make it look like he was
dodging the pipe then the crew shot the
pipe rig on its own while replicating
the speed and positioning of the camera
as closely as possible we track the
camera within all those environments and
we do a lot of like reprojecting so that
we can bring it all into one camera
basically in the end changes in the edit
meant digital domain had to make this a
fully cg shot but many of the original
movements from the camera and the actor
are still there we do try even if we're
gonna exaggerate it to use the base of
what he's done and then you know
embellish it spider-man also has to
rescue the assistant vice chancellor
from her car as it teeters over the edge
of the bridge
the entire stunt was broken up into
three parts the car going over the
bridge
the car crashing through the guardrail
and the car dangling in the air this
required building a whole new set
while the main stretch of highway was on
the ground this one was elevated 20 feet
so the car could hang without hitting
anything first the car was placed on a
small track to move it forward then it
was guided by cables for the moment it
sputters out of control we wanted it to
look a little more natural when it got
hit and let it kind of just swing into
the railing as opposed to just follow
this exact mark to make the car crash
through the guardrail dan built a piece
of the rail out of beaded foam he then
painted it and plastered the edges
before pre-breaking it into smaller
pieces finally he put it back together
so the car could smash through it we
built 20 or 25 feet of breakaway because
you figured the length of the car was 16
17 feet long the car was later placed on
a gimbal in front of a blue screen so it
would look like it was really teetering
at a 90 degree angle over the edge the
gimbal was safe enough for actress paula
newsom to be inside the car so cameras
could capture her terrified facial
expressions filming her upside down was
particularly helpful for the vfx artists
you really get the dynamics with her
hair and the movement of her clothes and
all that and instead of looking out at
spider-man she's actually looking at a
tennis ball which was then easily erased
in post-production
as spider-man tries to pull her car to
safety doc ock throws another car at him
which hits some barrels instead
according to dan the director wanted it
to be raining water so dan had to
manipulate both the car and the barrels
this required putting a 20-foot nitrogen
cannon diagonally through the car that
cannon was attached to a high-pressure
accumulator to launch it forward dan
also filled the water barrels with
pyrotechnics linked to a timer we knew
the speed of the car going into the
barrels so we knew how many tenths of a
second it would take for the car to hit
all the barrels once the car hit the
first barrel each one blew up in order
at the speed the car was coming at them
the practical stunt looked great but the
trajectory was slightly off so using the
original shot as reference scott
actually replaced the car with a
completely cg model we needed the car to
start higher because dock was further
down the road and he was up on his arms
the car needed to kind of roll i was
going towards spider-man
many of these fighting shots actually
used digital doubles which worked out
since the nanotech powered iron spider
suit was created with cg you about done
yourself peter but because spider-man
removes his mask they couldn't just do a
full body swap like the assistant vice
chancellor on the gimbal they also
needed to film tom hanging in the air
the way he moves his body tilts his neck
holds himself is all reminiscent of
somebody actually hanging upside down
but the constant movement of the action
made it hard to accurately place the
iconic costume
so tom wore what's known as a fractal
suit the patterns on the suit gave
animators the easiest way to map the
digital body onto the actor's body if
his chest turns or moves or his arms are
moving you can see those patterns moving
easier than if he was just in like a
plane suit for the tentacles doc ox
jacket had holes in the back of it these
red tracking marks allowed vfx to
accurately place the arms despite the
constant moving camera and action you
can locate where the arm is and really
stick it to that little dot because if
it's swimming around then it looks like
it's swimming around on his back
after pulling the assistant vice
chancellor's car up spidey uses his web
blasters to pull the car door off
the web was a fully cg creation but on
set the special effects team needed to
create enough force to take the door off
by itself at first meant replacing its
hinge pins with ones made out of balsa
wood the door was then attached to a
cable from the outside that was powered
by a pneumatic piston the accumulator
lets the air rush into the piston piston
closes pulls the cable the door comes
off pre-destroying cars offset was also
useful for the moment when the green
goblin's pumpkin bomb explodes
the cars were actually taken apart and
then put back together before being
brought to set allowing for these
dramatic results and it was up to scott
and his team to enhance all these
crashes and explosions while populating
the shot and digitally extending the
bridge according to scott digital domain
created 250 static cars parked on the
bridge plus 1100 digital cars driving
around the city in the distance those
cars are all variations of just a
handful of digital car models meanwhile
the cars that were closest to the camera
needed to be digitally scanned they do a
basic texture shoot of photography for
like what the car looks like what the
texture is when adding these digital
cars in each car is then customized
based on the action on screen to ensure
continuity so the team had to keep track
of everything from dirt stains to the
exact position where a car was
originally placed there's like a whole
lot that goes in there just tracking
where everything lives so why even
bother shooting time-consuming and
complicated effects for real if so many
of them are replaced digitally it's all
invaluable reference for some very
unique ideas like how glass looks after
a car gets crushed the way that the
metal bends it's not always like super
sharp a lot of times it's kind of softer
curves the side windows sometimes when
it's getting crushed like that literally
like explode into like a bajillion
little tiny safety pieces and you never
know what real elements can make their
way into the final shot
we kept the water barrels exploding so
in that particular shot all that water
is real and we had to remove the
practical car from inside of all that
water and add our cg car
tom holland is extraordinarily athletic
and did a lot of his own stunts whether
we end up using the entire performance
or not it's really good reference for us
or we do use it and it's great to see
his physicality and how his body moves
and what he's doing because a lot of his
performance is coming from that now you
died